I think a lot of computer scientists
have been thinking about what they call
ubiquitous computing the idea that with
really good bandwidth and wireless at
that and fast processors there'll be
computers everywhere more than just in
your lap on a laptop or in a Hallmark
card when you open it and it sings you
happy birthday I'm interested in a
counterpart to that which I think of as
ubiquitous human computing and that is a
trend that's just starting to get ramped
up where we start to think of the human
mind as if it were a server as if it
were a commodity that you could throw at
a problem and ramp up by just investing
a little bit more money in your project
and we see this in three layers each of
which has an example company at work and
each example of which is really
interesting to me I like these companies
I like all three of them but in total I
see reason to I don't know be bemused
about what's happening at the top level
of this phenomenon is a company like
innocentive innocentive was started by a
big pharmaceutical concern to create a
marketplace for companies like itself
that might have engineering or
scientific problems to solve that aren't
exactly nobel prize worthy but are more
complicated than just something you
could send downstairs and to be able to
take those problems described them and
put a bounty on their solution $15,000
to the first person somewhere in the
world that can create a molecule that
has the following characteristics it
smells like this and it's machine
washable and there's a race on then
among those who tend to troll that site
a lot of unemployed chemical engineers
among others and somebody comes up with
the answer submits it it's validated
collects $15,000 and in exchange it's as
if he or she never had the idea that
becomes the property lock stock and
barrel of the company that commissioned
it for the money big money that have
paid for it so that's sort of on the
high end of putting problems out for
solution where your basic
indifferent who's solving the problem
what their motives are anything else you
may not even meet them or correspond
with them you just get a solution for
your money that required a human brain
in the middle then one notch down
there's a company like LiveOps LiveOps
from what I can tell extremely
successful and it's a company that will
employ anyone in America at the moment
who can get through its test and the
test is administered automatically over
its website a number of questions
reading comprehension kind of like a
mini essay t-test and other languages if
you've got them are tested and then they
also test your computer outfit do you
have a decent internet connection you
know how to use your pc more or less in
a working headset and of many many
people who might apply on one end only a
few fallout after hours of the tests on
the other end ready to be I wouldn't say
hired by LiveOps because they won't be
employees but in a working relationship
with them like contractors and then it's
almost like a video game you're in the
privacy of your own home maybe you've
got your kid in the playpen next to you
you turn on your liveops account and
where do you want to go today well maybe
when you first start it's just taking
pizza orders and you click you're given
a script and identity suddenly you're
working for pizza hut and then someone
calls what they think is pizza hut it
gets routed to your living room you say
welcome to Pizza you take the order you
type it in you click send and boom it
goes back out to the local pizza hut
from the person calling and the pizza
gets delivered this is an interesting
way of working because it gives you
enormous freedom you can be in your own
home you can plug in or out after every
single call you can work as much or as
little as you like but it also is a lot
of if not constraint surveillance the
calls and interactions are recorded
there are all sorts of metrics applied
so you'll be told if you're keeping up
on the number of calls per hour that is
expected
for this range and then as you succeed
at the little tasks you get on to more
and more complicated tasks liveops says
that when Hurricane Katrina hit
louisiana the American Red Cross came up
with an 800 number that people could
call for information try to find
relatives of course the American Red
Cross didn't have enough people to staff
it and turned to live ops liveops
immediately boom sent out the word and
those LiveOps agents who were working at
that moment all could transform
themselves into American Red Cross
representatives that's the middle zone
the zone below that is represented by
amazon's mechanical turk this is a
service whereby for maybe a penny or a
nickel tasks that are repetitive often
boring but that still require a human
brain of some kind in order to complete
our put out for bid and anyone with a
mechanical turk account can perform the
tasks so you might be asked to look at a
picture and identify what you see in the
picture and type in the key words of
what you see you might be told to go to
a website and interact with it in a
certain way go to this blog and leave a
comment with what you think go to this
amazoncom review site and leave a
positive review must be 5 out of 5 stars
that actually happened was discovered
and the company behind it roundly
denounced for astroturfing and when you
put these three things together I think
what you start to see is a way of
harnessing mental energy and action that
we just didn't have before that could be
very empowering but it also makes me
think about how easily one could put out
the call to call your member of Congress
tell them how much you hate or like
health care reform and that call would
be indistinguishable from that of any
regular constituent because you are a
regular constituent you
been primed by mechanical turk to do it
you then report on your call maybe even
send a transcript or a recording along
and you get paid your nickel or your
quarter or whatever else and that starts
to mean that any mass movement become
suspect because we have no idea how it
was motivated or who was asked now maybe
word could get out that that was going
on but as it happens more and more it's
not clear how scandalous it would be
it's just another set of tools used just
like we expect today that there will be
television commercials aired or
testimonials from people who have been
pre-screened on one issue or another so
as we enter a world in which I imagine a
subway car which everybody in the car is
basically traveling in silence staring
at a screen or talking quietly into
something and some of them are engineers
hoping to earn their fifteen thousand
dollars some of them are LiveOps people
checking in with their white collar
skills and others are latter-day mental
click worker sweatshop or doing one
nickel task at a time I look at that
subway car and I see a very different
configuration than the one we have today
even if most people are silent listening
to their iPods so it's a phenomenon
worth keeping